Hello! Welcome to Michael's Better Business English!
This month, we're looking at how to speak logically.
This is a very important skill in business communication...
...and one many Japanese business people find difficult.
The reason is often when Japanese business people are explaining their ideas,...
...they lack a logical structure.
This structure gives some organization...
...to make the ideas logical, easy to understand, and sound effective.
Now, there are many possible structures you could use to explain your ideas logically.
One that I'd recommend especially if you're, say, describing a project,...
...explaining something, or recommending a strategy is the SOAR statement.
This is a very simple but effective logical structure.
SOAR stands for situation, objective, actions, and result.
Situation, any useful background information.
Objective, the goal, the target of what you're talking about.
Actions, this could be an action plan or the actions you are taking to achieve your target.
And then finally, result.
What you expect to get at the end of this project or strategy, or whatever.
So, I normally recommend to my students, remember SOAR in business meetings or discussions,...
...or when somebody asks you to describe or explain something clearly.
This is an easy technique to help you speak logically.
Thank you and good luck!